alright folks let's get going we're
actually right on time by a mighty
standards which is we start as for those
of you are not from MIT five minutes
after the hour so that students can get
from class to class or welcome to a an
event that has taken some time to set up
this is the this is the virtuality
storytelling and social impact summit
for the lack of a better term it really
comes out of a couple of things it comes
out of a class that is being taught at
MIT a seminar class and also a really
wonderful research effort that's budging
at MIT so welcome my name is Sanjay
Sharma I'm professor of mechanical
engineering I'm vice president for open
learning and along with Kenzo Locke
where's Kent my co-conspirator we are
running a seminar series on seminar
actually on on virtual reality along
with Fox Herald race Fox Fox is involved
because he's actually teaching another
course and we're adjacent to each other
in the topic I'll introduce Fox in a
minute and we have students from the
seminar so this is also a class and we
also have visitors from outside MIT from
Berkeley from Harvard from Princeton
from all the way from LA and actually
from a very wide set of backgrounds so
you know I just want you to spend a
couple of minutes talking about what
we're trying to do here virtual reality
is a field that has emerged over the
last 20 30 years depending on how you
look at it Fox and I've talked about the
philosophy or what is virtuality and
it's not clear exactly what it is I
think he has a refined definition of it
and in my world this is the world of
open learning I have many colleagues
here and open learning we do we started
with massive open online courses MOOCs
on EDX we did a lot of work with
OpenCourseWare going 20 years ago
EDX I mean OpenCourseWare celebrated its
15th anniversary two or three years ago
so this whole business of online
education has really progressed over the
last two decades everything we do online
we also apply on campus
MIT and so this is a maturing field and
one that is exciting and interesting to
watch but we are still dealing frankly
with videos and sound and a really
enticing opportunity for all of us is
what happens as media becomes richer as
we can immerse ourselves in three
dimension tree in 3d environments as we
can immerse ourselves in virtual
environments defined more broadly as Fox
defines them can we make learning more
evocative can we make it more memorable
I have a couple of notes here from from
colleagues if you are a marine biologist
would you learn better if you could be
the turtle if you're studying marine
biology if you were studying angular
momentum would it be easier to learn it
and more memorable if you could be the
wheel right and so these are some of the
questions that led us to start working
on a new effort in virtual reality it's
as I said they were to conch to streams
that came together here one is the
seminar class and the other is focus
leadership in this really exciting area
so welcome to this event I'm not going
to take too much time I'm going to kick
it off but let me tell you what the run
of the show is we will start with a
panel discussion we have three very
eminent speakers and the speakers are
Professor Fox Harrell who leads up a
research in this effort at MIT and he
will talk about our new center for
advanced virtuality of which he is the
director after that we will have Shekar
Kapur an eminent there is director actor
has produced movies like Elizabeth for
feathers given many well-known Hollywood
stars their break-in in in media and
shaker will talk about film and
storytelling and we spent a lot of time
talking about and thinking about where
the story fits in the broader scheme of
producing content perhaps even in
learning and then finally Professor
Susan Rogers
from Berkeley we'll be talking about the
psychos to acoustics about psycho istic
acoustics spatial localization cues to
finding where sound comes from realism
what lists listeners know of how sounds
are made and individual differences in
perception with the tagline that not all
yours are made alike which brings us to
the second piece of this event so
usually when you have an event like this
you have a number of speeches and then
you have a number of speeches so this
time we decided to go differently we
have really great and diverse set of
speakers talking about the topics I
described and they will have a panel
session and then in the second half we
will take a very deep dive into
three-dimensional sound not
three-dimensional space but in addition
to three-dimensional space
three-dimensional sound and for that we
have two amazing colleagues Edgar whom
I've known a long time professor at good
shower shower who's a professor at
Princeton and an expert in
three-dimensional sound among other
things and he is the creator of a suite
of technologies under called bacc edge
buck and he'll talk about that work and
Mark mangini who is a celebrated audio
engineering and an expert on audio and
expert who's produced has worked on many
movies that many of you heard of and
he'll talk about sound and the
importance of sound in in in the media
so what we'll do now is we'll kick
things on we'll kick things off I'm
going to start by requesting professor
Fox Harrell to come and talk about our
new center I'm sorry folks I just want
to also make an announcement we have
we're recording the event if you don't
want to be seen on camera don't turn
back all right so first thanks to Sanjay
for the very gracious introduction I'm
very pleased to be here with esteemed Co
panelists today and have conversation
with you so well I'll talk to you about
is virtuality storytelling and social
impact
which is some of the kind of work that
we have been we've been exploring here
at MIT both within my research group and
then now also more broadly across the
Institute's you know through this new
initiative that uh Sanjay mentioned the
Center for Advanced virtuality yeah and
so I should mention also I'm professor
of digital media and artificial
intelligence here I'm in two units on
both in comparative Media Studies as
well as computer science an artificial
intelligence lab on campus so you really
crossed a lot of disciplinary boundaries
and the kind of work that we do so one
of the things that I do here is I found
it founded and direct a research group
called the imagination computation and
expression laboratory and so this group
brings together postdocs PhD students
which are usually electrical engineering
and computer science PhD students
comparative Media staff sir students
sometimes computer science master
students and undergraduate researchers
they're all together to do a few things
that includes in mentioning new forms of
interactive narrative video games social
media interactive narrative can be in
virtual environments we are fully
immersive spaces but also other types of
kind of immersive platforms are
distributed across the internet and so
forth and we produced and we also
analyze these kind of systems too so
besides using AI to make these systems
adaptive you know that is it's not just
about creating a kind of 3d virtual
space I mean that's a part of it but
asking questions such as could you use
artificial intelligence instead to
change the metaphor used to
express a concept or the emotional tone
on the fly or you know fix the plot but
change the perspective of a character or
even the cultural perspective and so for
us AI is really a way to enable very
dynamic uses of this kind of a medium
and we also analyze them to to make sure
that they're in line with a kind of
latest social theory you know that
they're not disadvantaging certain users
and so on so we produced a number of
different kind of works ranging from
interactive narrative and collaboration
with another group had at Georgia Tech
you know that is a memorial for the
Truth and Reconciliation Commission of
Liberia that shows the kind of issues
that took place after 14 years of civil
war from a variety of stakeholder
perspectives there are 15 different
ethnic language stood groups there as
well as a number of themes that emerge
from that process so this is how do you
memorialize that through a kind of
interactive display now it works
addressing issues ranging from everyday
discrimination to how we manage our
impressions in everyday situations and
so I'll tell you later just about a
little bit of a kind of work that we do
but when it just to give you a sense of
the kind of broader array of projects
and now one of the things that we've
been doing here Sanjay mentioned is
launching a new Center that's under open
learning called the MIT Center for
Advanced virtuality and the aim is to
think about these issues at scale across
the Institute and then also across the
boundaries of other researchers are
pursuing this of this area and that's
aiming to support innovation and
research of technologies and especially
experiences of virtuality and so I can
tell you a little bit in a moment to
just about what this kind of virtuality
means in our particular point of view I
want to just take the view a sense of
what the function is of this kind of a
center that is it operates both as a
studio and lab you know that is making
and understanding and doing you know and
as well as capacity building you know
that is salon events consolidating
resources and matchmaking between
students faculty and projects
and so that means making that's focused
on expression and innovation research
that is how do we understand the impacts
of these kind of systems you know what
is the cognition of user you know the
issues like embodied cognition as you
move throughout these spaces that they
change the way that you understand
yourself as you go through these kind of
experiences and then assessment and in
terms of both the system doing what it's
saying that it's that it's doing there's
a lot of buzz around this ideas like
empathy that is if people imagine well
just because you look like someone else
in the virtual world that maybe you
should understand other experiences in
fact we think it's not true in the sense
that just the 3d graphical appearance is
not enough we actually have to simulate
the experiences and phenomena and
systematicity of social phenomena so we
use the term sometimes in the field
social physics the way that in computer
graphics you have physics engines we
think about this as a kind of social
physics engine that can enable these
kind of systems then other side events
for capacity building here at MIT as
well as ways to enable student
involvement student clubs have stood on
the courses across campus and shared
resources and in forming the vision of
the center you can ask what is virtue
alley and how widespread is this and how
impactful is are these technologies so I
could begin just by asking how many
people here by a show of hands have used
some type of virtual reality technology
right yeah so almost everybody you know
that's in the room and how about mixed
reality technologies so about nearly as
about nearly as many so you get a sense
of the kind of pervasiveness of some of
these kind of technologies although it
is a kind of selected audience that we
have here but we think about this and
also a kind of a broader way than this
these particular kind of devices and so
for us that means experiences ranging
from taking on identities in 3d virtual
worlds like you just indicated by your
show of hands but also encounters online
and so one way to think about this is
real experiences in some sense but not
primarily physical experiences that are
enabled by the computer and the reason
we like to use this kind
definition is because would think about
issues such as learning let's say if you
learned something in a virtual
environment and it transfers to the
physical world in everyday life you know
there's some sense in what you don't
want to say well that wasn't real
learning that was just some kind of
virtual learning that doesn't apply
anymore and then the flip side the
negative you know where you have issues
of say harassment or bullying even to
the point of a self-harm online you
don't want to dismiss those kind of
experiences and say there's some sense
in which they're not real they're just
virtual experiences so for us advancing
the state of computer-based VR systems
XR systems every reality type of a
system means better serving human need
through artful innovation that means
exploring the aspects of ourselves
environments and society that we can
imaginatively construct atop the
physical world using these technologies
and so that means we focus on creation
of new genres the aesthetics and the
kind of conventions of this which in
some sense although there is about a 30
year arc you know by some by some
metrics there also isn't yet a kind of
set of conventions in the same way that
we have say for feature or film
research to understand the critical
learning and social ethical impacts and
then finally a cultural and economic
impacts that this can be produced at
scale yes so you mentioned I mean in
this room you could say that people have
used their systems that look somewhat
like this but virtuality is also
everywhere yeah so that means that if
you have some type of avatar in any type
of system even just on a forum you have
a 2d avatar
that's a virtual data identity that
exists there and if you have an online
account whether for online shopping or
social media and so forth or the kind of
virtual self yeah so in that sense of
virtuality extends across experience of
even more than the kind of expert users
so we might have here but also everyday
users and and a lot of ways and when you
think even about some of the primary
modes to which people engage these
experiences as such as video games and
computer games you say that such uptake
you know 68% of people in the
having played these types of games and
then at the same time
56% male versus 44% female right in some
sense it's not even but it belies the
kind of stereotyped assumptions about
who's using these technologies so we can
design and build these systems for
social impact we can also try to
understand what are the best practices
and what are the baseline principles
regarding the use of these virtual
selves so just to give some sense of
this
we did a some set of studies you know
that's over a thousand users total to
understand how do virtual identities
impact us when we are engaged in
learning in virtual environments that is
if you have a self in between you and
the subject matter like some type of
avatar or profile does that impact
impact your learning your performance
and the engagement and so we thought one
of the basic distinctions is the
anthropomorphic and non anthropomorphic
you know that's one of the kind of beta
basic kind of divides you know that we
might have in terms of self
representations online
another one is likeness versus non
likeness do you try to make it like you
or is this something different than you
and so we actually found that all things
being equal actually the very abstract
ones are those that engage users they
perform the best and are most engaged
under but at the same time that doesn't
tell the whole story
because in fact a lot of users actually
live up or down to the stereotypes of
their real world categories when they
use these so this is well-known in
learning sign there's a stereotype
threat but this actually happens true as
well when you use virtual selves that is
if you are from some category that
people assume might not be good at say
STEM fields and you have an avatar you
know that's is from your category that
looks like you then you actually perform
worse and are less engaged but that also
didn't tell the same the whole story so
for example role models that's one way
to mitigate against these kind of
effects but as well needed studies for
Desert View create this instantly does
it take a long time to make it and so
forth and found that in some cases you
have four different demographic groups
different impacts and then now don't
print demographic groups also different
avatar types because forth um they see
this as an externalization of themselves
and now that is they say in a video game
I want to jump onto those bricks and
others say I want Mario to jump onto
those bricks it actually makes a big
difference in terms of how this impacts
you as a learner the final project that
I mentioned to you is a recent VR
journalism collaboration called the
enemy with a cream Ben Khalifa who was a
director of this project I was the
human-computer interaction producer and
this was a project about humanizing the
other in the face of war and so it
constructs a environment it looks like
this it's in a room actually larger in
this room it's been shown at a number of
museums Tribeca Film Festival and so on
and you counter combatants from of
different global conflicts with gang
members in El Salvador each side within
East Congo and then finally now as well
you have soldiers in Gaza Israeli and
Palestinian competant and as you go
through these experience these soldiers
are asked basic human questions like
have you killed before where do you see
yourself in ten years what is peace for
you what is war for you and then the
kind of parallels and differences
between these answers you begin to get a
sense of this kind of common humanity so
that's not to ignore the kind of history
that exists within each of these kind of
locations but on the individual level it
gives a chance to go through the space
and see that in fact there are parallels
and white people in each of these
conflicts talk about these experiences
it's customized you register it shows
you the experience that the more that
you are least experienced with as a very
last one if you've been through
traumatic experiences yourself then we
also dial down the experience there's a
lot of kind of customisation that takes
place and most importantly it's reading
proxies for your nervousness and bias as
you go through the experience so that
means it's standing very stiffly and
attentively or you're kind of moving
around and shuffling a lot or you change
your body all these body language cues
tell us about how you're feeling as you
go through these experiences and the
narrative actually shapes according to
the trajectory of your navigation
ranging from the lighting in the room if
you're very best then you have the
feeling of a cloud obscuring the Sun on
the partly cloudy day everything becomes
darker you'll be very attentive it
becomes suddenly a brighter and warmer
you'll get feet
different kind of endings the stories
are evocative depending on whether you
move towards less bias or more bias and
then finally you move you see a virtual
soldier and you okay it's actually
moving along with me and you realize
that you to the other users because 15
people go through this at a time you
realize that you have become the soldier
that you are the least comfortable with
by the end that is you could be like
your enemy if you were raised in the
same way and so I'll just conclude by
just showing a brief brief trailer from
the works you can get a greater sense of
this and the wrap-up
[Music]
if we can bring down the lights a little
bit too
[Music]
the enemy was born out of my frustration
as a photojournalist and more
correspondent for almost 20 years I have
photographed conflicts and witnessed the
consequences of huge geopolitical shifts
when I became a father I simply knew I
could not keep working on the front
lines
[Music]
yet I was not done trying to understand
warrants
[Music]
oh never what you know about any walk my
friends in Israel when they know I'm
heading for Gaza can't help themselves
but to wish me luck
interests they safe
they believe a lot of people in Gaza I
irrational also when I spent weeks
working in Gaza and I'm about to return
to Israel my Palestinian friends are
telling me the exact same thing be
careful there
[Music]
the project is rooted in my experience
as a war photographer going from one
side of the frontline to the other and
finding that the fighters dreams hopes
and nightmares often most similar and
they are different so there is a bigger
story than the war itself and this is
the one I want to explore and share
for the enemy I am using the latest
technologies in virtual and augmented
reality so you can engage directly with
the combatants and meet them hear them
and feel them the way I did in many part
of our walls you create the enemy as a
kid without having met your enemy
because the society around you has
created an enemy in the other so the
question is could I be you if I was on
the other side
[Music]
thank you right so I'll just you know we
could talk more about that later but
I'll just say that in the actual
experience there were profound moments
of compassion we found in users that
went through the experience regardless
of kind of which side of the conflicts
they've been closer to and even from the
combatants themselves asking about the
welfare of each other having gone
through this experience so to conclude I
feel that innovation and virtuality is
crucial because nearly everybody uses
these technologies these days have some
type of virtual identity you know so we
again Asante suggested we think very
broadly about to virtuality and
increasingly these kind of platforms are
interconnected worlds you know that's
how we operate within and then finally I
believe that we must take a thoughtful
approach to considering these kind of
technologies of virtuality because they
span across how we communicate express
clay and ultimately as is our aim impact
Society thank you very much
thank you very much Fox next up I'm
going to request Shekar Kapoor to come
up and speak and I'm a little story
Shekar was telling me that he was at
Davos a few years ago and I think Bill
Gates was speaking and there was a
question about what the future of media
was gonna be and Shekar posited that the
future of media is I think you said a
technology company should new studios
are going to be the technology companies
are going to be the new studios
technology companies are going to be the
new studios and did he agree with you he
said we don't understand content I said
if you don't understand content all
technology companies ultimately will
survive on content and in fact today
Netflix and Amazon and Apple have become
content producers so my question to you
Shekar just to kick off your session is
now in 2018 looking forward as someone
who's been in the media industry you can
sit there you can get you don't have
slides what is where is where is
storytelling narrative video all that
stuff gonna go in the next five 10 years
and and what are you seeing at MIT in
your in your in your sabbatical here I
think is that we need we misunderstand
is what story is and I think one of the
things that are noticing all around me
not only here but also in Hollywood and
film businesses and traditional
businesses all over the world a story
has become what we call a three-act
structure it never was a three-act
structure it only became a three-act
structure because of her technology and
that technology was the Gutenberg press
and certainly you could publish your
stories you could disseminate them and
the three axes structure came out came
across before the three-act structure we
told stories so what was different we
told stories we just narrated stories
and they never ended they'd ever ended
now how do you have a never ending story
in a three-act structure you can't so
that completely explodes the whole
theory if the storytelling as we got
used to so the first thing when I
started I started I'm trying to learn
virtual reality and all these things
because I thought I'm going to become a
dinosaur if I don't because this is a
new way what is a new way we tell
stories because ultimately
all expression has been dominated by the
techniques the technology of what is
offered for that so in you know the
times of the caveman the the technology
was a stone against the wall my daughter
when she was growing up it was crayon
then as you publish you typed then you
made films each time a technology is
offering something and the world is
moving so what is this technology and
what is it offering to be the first
thing it's offering is is a new way to
express it's offering me a new way to
emote right in order to understand what
is this new thing called virtual reality
I went back to understand actually there
is nothing but virtual reality my
perception of what you know sorry
Christina so Christina I'm looking at
you I cannot have a pure experience of
you that's not how my mind works my mind
works I look at Christian and I'm
already told a story about myself about
you to myself in order to perceive you
if we had pure perception as Buddha said
he had pure perception
he didn't need stories but our
perception of the world is virtual in
any case there's nothing there's nothing
absolutely real we create the universe
in our own perception what is our own
perception our own perception is the
story we tell everywhere I'm looking I'm
even looking at the desk and it's a
story for me because if it's not a story
I don't understand it my mind does not
understand anything but stories so now
we have this thing called virtual
realities an immersive we call it
immersive what can we do and I was
thinking you know Fox you saying I was
thinking what would I like to do we
should all be driven by what we want
what does what do people want I want to
meet my father my father passed away 10
years ago could you develop a technology
what is that story between me and my
father almost 50% of the films that we
make are unresolved issues between
parents and us father son mother
daughter and let me just talk about this
issue called resolution one of
big problems that we do is we think
stories resolve themselves actually
things were resolved the universe will
collapse there's no absolute evil
there's no absolute good everything
would collapse if we everything got
resolved and that's what's great about
you're the enemy nothing gets resolved
something is understood and that what is
understood is creating a million new
questions and out of that a million new
questions arise and that's how we used
to tell stories there's this great book
in Hinduism called Mahabharat how many
have heard of it
yeah yeah it's it's volumes and volumes
and volumes but actually before it was
published it was a million times volumes
because everybody was narrating their
own version of that and nothing got
resolved because out of one problem came
another one resolution so we created
harmonies so can I walk into this and
and try and resolve something that I
faced my father and all the unanswered
questions my father was a doctor I want
to ask him did you believe in God and
then at the end of it can I reverse
physicians can I become my father and
the cross means me can we do that what
am I really saying I'm saying that this
gives us the opportunity to discover
stories not to tell stories I learned
storytelling from my grandmother my
grandmother would tell me a story but
what was she really doing she was
creating an embryo a cocoon a nurturing
environment in which I was a voice like
I'm talking to you now is the way she is
to talk to me and I would be lost in
that environment and she would tell me a
story maybe because the story we all
know is wrong in Juliette but as she was
narrating a story I was narrating a
different story imagining a different
story to myself and then I would just
wallow in it and I would be imagining a
different story
Blount for my childhood experiences or
imagining and then suddenly said and you
know what Julia said it yeah yeah it's a
touch point so we go from touch point to
touch point to touch point which is
actually what we do in cinema right we
go from
little touch points in touch one tax
week what we call those touch points
plot right can we so what are we doing
the greatest films that have ever been
made last why doesn't film last why do
you want to film 20 times because when
you're watching that film 20 times each
time you watch that film you are
reinterpreting the story of the film
according to who you are at that moment
not who you were 10 years ago or even 10
days ago who are you at that moment and
so you are actually telling your own
story and the reason you know I watched
2001 Space Odyssey again and again every
time I see it I understand it
differently so in virtual reality we
have this amazing tool by which you are
in because that's what we do anyway the
great films say what is engagement
engagement is your ability or the film's
ability or the storytellers ability or
the technology's ability to encourage
you to create your own story out of the
various touch points that I've given you
all the technology gives you and
therefore whenever i watch so when you
walk in into this virtual reality but
I'm fascinated by is the way we
encourage story learning story imagining
is by taking those torch points and then
expanding them and then expanding them
expanding the distance between those
touch points and in that distance you
are encouraged to to take those things
in those distances tell your own story
in that and so at the end it's your
story which is why I want to face my
father of all the unreserve all to
resolve questions between me and my dad
because ultimately what you'll be able
to do is expand those pauses expand
those touch points include other
incidents in that and I'm resolving it
how am i resolving it I am harmonizing
it by creating myself is this a not a
great tool to understand yourself and
ultimately what is storytelling
we are the stories that we tell
yourselves ourselves we are beyond
nothing but the story we tell ourselves
so can then what I think virtual reality
and this is why I may as
I was fine I'm trying to understand how
to provoke what we've been trying to do
a storytelling artist all our lives as
storytellers if you go to Marrakesh you
got these little markets in Marrakesh
and then you stole it story tell us
everybody's sitting around and start
having a story they start telling then
somebody will give them a little bit
more money and say oh that character can
you tell me the story of that character
now you could go on telling the stories
a story out of a story out of a story so
we have the opportunity in this to
create new stories Sanchez has told you
five minutes I can go on for five hours
but is there any one question one
question Sanjay that you have yeah we'll
do questions at the end okay okay all
right but one last question for you so
and but but you have two minutes all
right but for me just to sort of fill up
the one minute that they have left for
you yeah so what how do you think that
in five years or ten years do you think
we'll be making movies the way we do
today or are we done in ten years and
everything will be a VR experience and a
game listen when radio came to I said
his movies you know when TV came into
said his movies that movies are alive
when video came to said movies dead
movies are alive but Netflix came to
said movies are dead you what we have to
understand is what the question you're
asking is the the concept the experience
of theater going it's not moviemaking
it's the experience of theater going and
Marco come and tell you they did the
sound for something called Furies no
sound led you there right so it's the
experience of Ted it's a question is a
little different is will the experience
of theater going make people go way
fewer in India it's the only place you
can go into the dog and hold your
girlfriend's hand so why would that go
away but yes but yes the experience of
what happens is as commercials did when
if commercials first came they were the
cutting edge of storytelling the
experience of video games became the
cutting edge of storytelling in cinema
the experience of virtual reality and
immersiveness
has to be accepted enveloped and created
again
on cinema otherwise fits in a little die
thank you thank you very much shaker so
our third speaker is Professor Susan
Rogers I've gotta tell you a little bit
of trivia about her she's worked with
Prince and barenaked ladies in her in
her career and what I'm really excited
about is to hear about psychoacoustics
because it really also tees up our next
presentation some Susan I do know I
didn't put while we're doing this it's
funny that's it that one there yeah as
our technology is getting us to a closer
and closer approximation of reality our
behavior oh thank you what do I do with
this okay thank you so as our technology
gets us closer to imitating reality our
behavior is getting us further away from
reality I was at BO Loco yesterday and
there was a young woman in front of me
and she had a phone and she was watching
a TV program on her phone and as a brain
scientist I'm just wondering what is
that doing so all around her is reality
in her hand is not reality she's got the
earbuds in and she's watching actors
saying you know fake for trails of real
people or real people portraying fake
people and saying words that have been
written for them fake life which is
preferable to real life depending on how
you feel about Bo loca but what are we
doing so what happens if we get our
virtual reality so close to reality will
it appear to be so close to real life
that we kill the goose that laid the
golden egg and have the consumer say you
know this is too much like life I don't
like it anymore because I rejected life
in the first place in order to have an
official experience it's a theoretical
question but I suppose that's what
psychologists do so I was just going to
talk a little bit about psycho acoustics
and what the field is and how psycho
acousticians can inform creators of
virtual reality content so psycho
acousticians look at how pressure waves
acoustic pressure waves in air become
transduced into a neural representation
a pattern of neural activity in the
nervous system that represents a sound
and it's really cool to think about
because right now I could play for you
and I kind of wish I was right now but I
could play for you some Led Zeppelin and
depending on your age and your
experience with Led Zeppelin I know for
me as soon as I hear Led Zeppelin I'm
gonna be picturing John Bonham on drums
and it's gonna be great and I'm gonna be
picturing Robert Plant and Jimmy Page on
that guitar and it's gonna be awesome so
what happens is there's a Saku stick
pressure wave and in my brain it's gonna
be different than in your brains in your
cochlea and all of our cochlea is it'll
be more or less the same then there'll
be this pattern of neural activity and
if you're young there's gonna be more
representation in the high frequency end
and if you're older you might have lost
a little bit but whatever it becomes a
pattern of activity but then a shaker
was just saying this what does that mean
nothing okay
oh okay I thought I had to go so in your
head it's gonna be a different story for
everyone depending on the life you've
lived the experiences you had and
depending on your ability to picture
John Bonham and John Paul Jones and
Robert Plant and and Jimmy Page so every
experience we have is filtered through
every experience we've ever had your
generation young people lucky you are
the first generation to be able to
design musical instruments that don't
physically exist so now when I listen to
techno or electronic dance music I'm
hearing sounds and there's no physical
core
of that I can't picture what made that
sound I have no idea what made that
sound so what's that gonna do to my
daydreams I don't know what that is I
don't have people to imagine I don't
have an instrument to imagine what am I
gonna think about I don't know remains
to be tested we'll find out in this new
world new to me
so anyway psycho acoustics it looks at
for one thing of many we look at spatial
localization how do we localize
something in 3d space it's actually a
matter of life and death to be able to
tell if you're walking you're an ancient
proto human and you're walking through
the grass and you hear a little rustling
behind you do you freeze or do you run
what is that rustling represent what
caused that thing to rustle I don't know
it's a snake
is it your kid who knows but you had to
be able to make that computation very
quickly to be able to make the right
decision so the this process tells us
where and what a sound source is whether
it's approaching or retreating and how
fast and what kind of environment it's
in when things get very close to us we
hear more highs and more lows and when
they get further away it rolls off the
high-end and low-end Sanjay had
mentioned bare naked ladies
I didn't work with naked women I worked
with the Canadian band bare naked ladies
and it was fun to do it was fun to mic
an amplifier and then mess with the EQ
at the top and the bottom end to see if
I could approximate a small thing right
in your face or something that sounds
like a massive thing at a distance and
then as I bring up the fader and get it
closer and closer and closer to me I
know to expand at the top and the bottom
end to make it more real
today's young audio engineers are
learning these things as well by
learning about psycho acoustics so
realistic sound design better enables
consumers to respond emotionally to
stories this image is from Klein
technologies if you're interested in
that sort of thing you can look it up
but I'm using it to illustrate the point
that the the inventions that we do here
can have downstream effects that we
don't anticipate for example what that
is
it's a monitor mixer for musicians on
stage but it's a 3d monitor mixer so the
drummer can be sitting there and he's
got his iPad next to him and now instead
of listening to a stereo signal that's
just killing him because it's so loud
has to be louder than his drums he can
take his finger on that iPad and he can
move the different instruments on stage
behind him out of his stereo image he
can he can have a 3d image and when you
click back and forth on their
demonstration between stereo and 3d the
first thing I noticed is that when it's
3d you can turn it down and we can
preserve their hearing that matters a
great deal to me because I work with
musicians at Berkeley these technologies
can have downstream effects but
essentially what we know from psycho
acoustics is that there's a sound source
and you're blindfolded if something's
coming from here all I have to do is
rotate my head and rotating my head is
going to tell it's going to change the
signal in both ears and that's going to
tell me where it's coming from but if
something I'm hearing a sound and I turn
my head in that sound doesn't change it
must be coming from directly above me or
directly below me so if you're a sound
designer and you've got the dragon on
the screen and the dragon is huh it's
not there it's above me how do you
design those cues so that we
realistically recognize that dragon is
straight above us and not in front of us
how fun I would like to do that so just
a picture of some microphones but the
folks who are designing microphones to
pick up realistic more realistic
acoustic waves are setting them inside
ears do we want that do we need that
would that be good well I don't know it
would be fun to mic a drum kit with
those microphones and see we're just so
used to hearing sounds the way we've
always heard them sometimes we don't
like new things great the great engineer
Frank Phillip Eddy just recently decided
to rather than mic instruments the way
he always had with the microphone in
front of it where the the instrument
produces its sweet spot
instead he said what if I might
these instruments from the player's
perspective instead of putting the mic
here for the acoustic guitar or the
cello let me put the mics here so we did
a whole recording and he sent it to me
and I listened to it I didn't like it I
didn't like it because it sounded as
though I were playing I don't want to
play I want to listen I want to be the
listener that's my role here our
perceptions do change our reality and it
has been said the human brain treats a
new idea the way the human body treats a
new protein it initially rejects it I
don't like it because it's new takes us
a little minute ears are shaped slightly
differently and those slight differences
lead to big differences in
high-frequency processing simply not all
ears are the same that's 8 different
traces from 8 8 different people it's a
nice paper but you see up there at the
high frequency and right around 6 or 8 K
is where there are great differences
between people simply based on the shape
of their ears and you can tell yourself
all you have to do is move the shape of
your ear around a little bit and it's
that high frequency that's really going
to change little movements lead to big
differences no HR TF is head related
transfer function and psycho
acousticians map those things the
experts in this room know far more about
this than I do so I won't get out of my
depth but researchers today are looking
for new algorithms to develop scene
aware audio to blend with 360 video this
paper just came out last month
and the researchers are from Adobe the
Adobe corporation as well as Columbia
University and what they're doing is
really clever so rather than having a
Namba sonic microphone with several
different angles
they're allowing you to take a track
that was recorded with a single mono mic
and then they're just performing the
computations so you take that audio
signal you add the delays of the room
that you're in which is easily found by
just doing the math
you're gonna have a height and a width
and a depth and you take that and then
for the tail end of it you you take you
have an impulse response measurement we
know that this room is cement and
there's this acoustical treatment over
here and that's probably drywall on the
ceiling I suppose and there's some glass
up there and the room is so big we can
we can do the math that's pretty easy to
figure out so the end result is you can
have a realistic space for every kind of
audio from a single mono microphone it's
the Adobe folks that are very interested
in this and they do things like plot how
energy from different distances from the
sound source behaves over time as you
can see it converges at the top image up
there this bottom image here is from a
paper from the great Josh McDermitt who
was here at MIT for for a while he's
he's a giant in the field of music
perception and cognition kind of a young
rock star anyway this is a paper from
2013 and he and his graduate students
were looking at something really
interesting and they were providing
evidence for the fact that the brain is
constantly performing computations to
tell us where we are so he showed with
the texture discrimination up there at
the top he presented to his listeners
for example the sound of rain outside
your window second sound would be more
rain outside your window the third sound
would be pebbles falling on a hard
surface like plastic or something and
your job was to guess which one of these
is different from the others and that's
the textured discrimination timeline and
blue there and he showed that the longer
the excerpt the closer people could get
to a correct decision that of
recognizing pebbles falling on a surface
versus real rain they were really good
about that
because the longer the exposure to a
sonic environment the more data we have
to tell us what sort of reality we're in
but the opposite was true the red line
for the exemplar discrimination and this
was the more interesting data which
sound was
different from the other two so the
first couple of sounds for example would
be exactly the same rain outside your
window followed by the exact same sound
example rain outside your window
followed by rain outside a different
window and that's when the longer it was
the worst performance got because the
brain just decided this is rain I'm
going with it and didn't bother to
segregate those two because there was no
useful relevant information in the
differences so if you're designing
something if you're designing audio for
a film or a story or a game or something
it would behoove you to know a little
bit about how the brain computes what
reality is and it's really important to
understand I tell the Berkeley students
this all the time you must understand
that musical training in childhood
develops the auditory path from the
cochlea all the way up to the cortex
hear such that musicians become auditory
athletes and they are capable of faster
and more accurate processing of sounds
compared to non musicians and when I
show these kids some of these slides
I've got plenty of data to back up this
point there are drastic differences for
example this comes from the great Nina
Krauss and her colleagues it's showing
in red in the red trace musicians and in
the black trace it's non musicians and
it is what she presented to them was a
dyad there was two notes and I think if
I remember correctly well it's the two
notes depicted on the bass staff there
and I'm not a musician so I don't
remember what they are anybody tell me
thank you
Jeanne so there's a low note there's a
higher note but when she presents this
dyad to listeners the musicians
automatically attended to we see in the
blue circles up there on the red trace
the upper overtones to tell them what
musical interval this was the non
musicians as you
see on the black trace there in the
green circles attended to the
fundamental frequencies the trace that
she's measuring that where she derived
this data from is auditory brainstem
response it's the same thing I do in my
own laboratory looking at the automatic
pre categorical pre cognitive processing
by the auditory system musicians through
virtue of their their training
automatically are going to attend to the
musical information in something like a
musical signal whereas non musicians
can't do it it's not that there's
anything wrong with their hearing it's
that they are not going to attend to
those relationships because it's not
relevant and in their experience
Nina Krauss and her colleagues also
showed that music lessons improve
auditory signal processing for all types
of sounds music speech and environmental
noise and the more music lessons you've
had the better able you are to segregate
speech and noise so if you're watching a
movie and multiple actors are speaking
against a noisy background or in a
reverberant environment musicians are
going to be better able to hear what's
being said they're also going to be
better able to extract words from people
who are speaking with a heavy accent
because they've got that superhighway
that allows them to process sound better
than the non musicians so sound
designers in the room if you're mixing
your audio and you happen to be a
trained musician pull in a few non
musicians pull in your mom pull in your
dad make sure that they can hear the
same thing that you hear as well
memory for sounds in the auditory cortex
and elsewhere pitch perception and
hearing in noise is far better for
musicians than non musicians due to the
neural architecture that supports
auditory processing this is comparing
musicians on the Left non musicians on
the right the bottom figure there is an
autocorrelation an autocorrelation is a
mathematical function that extracts
regularity from something so if you've
got a pitched vowel or a pitched musical
instrument tone
of course it's gonna repeat every X
number of milliseconds because that's
why it has a pitch musicians are able to
extract that automatically in their
processing non-musicians it's scrambled
pretty drastic differences there there's
wonderful data out there I'm going to
end with thank you but I've got a good
just a fun thing to tell you about I
hope you think this is fun some recent
studies over and Hungary we're
interested in dogs what dogs know about
processing audio processing and facial
processing and so they brought 17
domestic dogs into the laboratory and
they would have a screen and the screen
would show either a human face or a dog
face and the human the picture of the
human face was a stranger someone they'd
never seen before with two different
kinds of expression both human and dog
happy and angry human and dog paired
with a voice happy or angry human and
dog a voice speaking a foreign language
that these dogs had never heard before
and what the researchers were interested
in is if the dogs could recognize a
disconnect between a happy looking face
with an angry looking human voice in
both human and dog exemplars and they
could easily without any special
training what that tells us is that's
innate and we can extrapolate from that
finding and recognize that if dogs can
recognize your face doesn't match the
tone of your voice certainly human
beings can do it and we do it really
really well so sound designers you do
need to know something about the cues
that are present in an audio signal that
convey all manner of things from spatial
localization to you know the room you're
in to the mood you're in so that you can
make things real and design those
dragons that have a real voice and those
ETS that have a voice that makes us say
something from another planet I've never
seen anything like that before you can
do it but check out the work of some
psycho acousticians before you do so
thank you Fox over we'll do some Q&A so
as we're getting settled in I just shane
hands on my quest Shane Shane vanished
okay so I'm gonna pass this around if
you have any questions if you could come
to the mic anyone let me as we get going
let me just ask Fox a question how long
before we can create personalities
[Music]
[Applause]
and when you think but for me what's
interesting is when you think about the
original Turing test it wasn't just kind
of computer emulate a person right it
was in the situated within this
imitation game and actually involved
these other kind of issues of gender
here so for Alan Turing the original
test was about you can you have a man
that's imitating a woman and a computer
imitating a woman and then can the
person distinguish which one is which
and so that's the additional kind of
layer all the kind of socio-cultural
information that you would need if you
understand okay well it's not just is a
human conversation but what particulars
subculture or what particular
personality and so forth is this agent
possessing so I think that's what's afar
off the kind of common sense and the
kind of nuance and the kind of cultural
simulation the kind of simulation of
kind of basic human functionality in
terms of turn-taking and so forth and
possibility I think we're much closer in
that dimension duh so again if you have
questions we had come down to the mic
for I can pass this mic up you have a
question here great talks thank you very
much this is for shakaar in the near
future and think about your story about
you and your dad well people not die
you know the moment people who come from
India know I come from India the first
question is do you believe in
incarnation reincarnation the it's a
deeper question our addiction to
individuality is the question do we
believe you're individuals if our
addiction to individuality is so strong
then you will always look for how do
does I the individual survive after that
now if you start examining that question
what survives after death if you and so
when you say I have pretty good answer
for that if you say I survive after
death you have to understand who is I I
is nothing but a thought so really your
question becomes then
does thought survive after that
obviously it doesn't right so does can
we have individuals yeah you can have a
likeness that survived but you have to
understand what you're looking for when
you would answer this question of
personality a personality and a person
is two different things the question
really should be could we recreate a
person but a personality and and a
person they're two different ideas and
which is why some in Japan some of the
manga pop stars are huge stars they're
not persons their personalities so
there's a very complex question can we
recreate somebody of the one they're
dead you can recreate everything else
and yeah you can give them a personality
which may not be the personality of that
person so you have to divide between the
two to understand that question this is
a question for the whole panel the this
is a blessing side of the things we've
been talking about the ability to to add
so much powerful effect into all these
experiences seems you know there's a
great upside but there's also I know it
feels like a lot of risks that we face
about being manipulated by things that
we might not want to be manipulated by
and I'd love to get your thoughts on how
to deal with that blessing curse
questions maybe you can how do not be
manipulated by things that we don't want
to be manipulated by right um we would
say working with artists in the music
business that everything influences you
because a lot of fans without Basking
artists what inspired this song
everything everything inspires you I
don't know how we can be I honestly
don't know the answer like how we can
guard ourselves from experience I really
don't know it's a it's a it's an
interesting it's interesting for me to
be here and to hear the talks about
virtual reality because scientists
worship the truth
we worship truth what really is
and it raises a lot of philosophical
questions about what really is and and
how do you prove what really is and and
so it we may enter a dangerous time
where people who have been manipulated
to such an extent that they could not
accurately tell you the difference
between what happened and what they
believe happened that will be
interesting I don't know that that human
brains have any protection against that
I'm not saying it's a bad thing I'm
saying it's a curious question to ponder
so unexplored territory so find out a
whole panel yes so I think one yeah so
first thing I mean I agree it's such a
kind of crucial issue although I might
also contend that it's a different set
of modalities that these technologies
offer not necessarily starting with the
agreement point that they are more
persuasive in general their particular
forms of persuasion and I mean there's a
lot of studies with issues like false
memory and so forth and virtuality
with virtual reality technologies but at
the same time of course sometimes you
know face-to-face contact is journalists
know very you know very well yeah this
is kind of different grassy that takes
place and a mediated experience so
that's just questioning a bit of a mess
at the same time is acknowledging the
intense danger and so one of the kinds
of things the kind of things that we do
within the lab is first of all turning
the lens of the technology around so
using AI techniques to analyze the media
as well yes so what do things like take
a best-selling video game so we studied
one video game that on its best on the
first day release made about two hundred
and fourteen million dollars by
comparison Star Wars on its best weekend
these are both adjusted for inflation
made about twenty-seven million dollars
so it's about a factor of nine in terms
of revenue but we able to show by
turning the lens of these machine
learning processes on this particular
game that in fact if you play as a
female character you're going to be
advantaged only in playing one of the
three major play patterns within the
game only a stealthy thief intelligence
or strength oriented you're going to be
distant
within this video game similarly we've
looked at hundreds of thousands
Instagram profiles to find the patterns
with which people use these across the
cultures and the kind of biases that
might be interested within them so I
think that's one thing we can begin to
do is turn the lens around to look at
the kind of bias and expose the bias
within the systems and then the final
thing I'll say is that you know so the
first level of persuasion that would be
something like creating the kind of new
persuasive understandings yes so you
know that's kind of you know like use
the term procedural rhetoric sometimes
but another level is giving people tools
to think with that presents multiple
kind of worldviews within them but I
think Shekar referred to this earlier it
is not giving the people the answers by
giving people the system simulating
systems and patterns of experience and
then they can begin to make their own
conclusions as they see systematicity
through these experiences that is
everyday discrimination it's not one-off
experience in fact there are patterns of
these kind of experiences now you can
put them together recognize those
patterns that's what you've learned from
the system and that's a different type
of a persuasion than just something like
propaganda it's a kind of a tool for
critical thinking
let me any questions would you mind just
coming up here so they could see
this is a question sort of for season so
sort of in relation to that entire thing
what happens when for example we come to
a point where we're able to simulate
either with voice masking or voice
simulation things that people say and
then in this sort of same lens how do
you tell sort of like whether or not
you're able to tell rain from pebbles
how do you tell simulated voice from non
simulated voice and what happens when
that becomes an issue like if that is
used to harm or damage someone in there
like you know their image or whatever do
you have any thoughts on how that might
play out so psychologists so I can't
speak to the social or cultural impact
of something like that happening I can
say when it comes to imitating a voice
humans are expert at voice recognition
we form something that's called a Tambor
template over the course of our
lifetimes we can recognize the unique
filter of each person's voice so well
that we can recognize our best friend or
our loved ones voice on the phone even
if it's a bad phone connection even if
that person happens to have a cold we
can still recognize the porosity of
their speech and we can still extract
from enough cues in that signal and from
the things that they're saying obviously
the context we can extract that and
recognize this is is someone who is very
familiar to me
likewise we can often recognize the
voices of celebrities if you play an
isolated clip of a celebrity I've never
met Al Pacino but if I heard a clip of
his voice saying something that I don't
recognize I still recognize it's Al
Pacino
so from film so humans are
really good at this we discount just how
powerful a computational engine is the
human brain 100 billion neurons
there's some serious math it's capable
of so if you were to design an algorithm
that would cleverly imitate a person's
voice to the extent that it could fool
everyone who knew that person well
you're doing some serious math and you
maybe there'd be better things you could
be doing with your time I don't know I
don't know if a criminal would be clever
enough to be able to do it but I can
tell you this it's probably easier to
fool us with facial recognition than it
is with auditory recognition because
sound is a faster it's a faster and a
cruder sensory mechanism than his vision
so um yeah be hard to fool us with sound
thanks for that great question
yeah go ahead actually take up a
previous thank you one little question
is you have to decide it's a moral
question where does teaching become
manipulation if you can answer that then
you're gonna see your yeah actually I
have we have one or two more minutes and
I just want to ask the panel one
question one final question I'll start
with you shaker if we could you know we
have sound behave video we can do sound
in 3d we can do visual in 3d if you had
haptics or the sense of smell let's
leave our taste for the time being good
would that change the way we made movies
Stevie what I got every every additional
technology that we can have to give you
a greater sense of the world we change
the world way we make movies because and
we're trying to replicate the world if
you just go silently you know watching a
forest ranger when my daughter was young
used to take her along a forest to make
a touch everything I make us hear every
sound and then bounce our sounds across
so that you understand the whole
environment so the more you give the
more we as filmmakers or as creators or
content makers will try and tap to your
reality as we think your reality is but
let's not forget a lot of
when you are telling your story and
you're creating a perception it's also
about what you take away well I mean we
were watching somebody when we're making
a film we suddenly they called sound
away and make it a very silent moment
even artificially silent to push on the
point and it tells its own story or you
know when every filmmaker in the world
when he's doing Romeo and Juliet when
Romeo see Juliet Juliet says Romeo
suddenly goes slow motion take a sense
of time away you know so he constantly
is also what you take away that tells a
story to excite you in a point and I
think Susan you talked about how the
eyes and sound collaborate visual and
auditory cues do you see this happening
smell touch etc etc and Fox I think it'd
be wonderful when it does when we can
integrate experiences from all of our
senses so that things feel more real I
don't know what we will do with that
additional information but as you know
as young consumers so now that we have
more information how how will it affect
our our love of stories I'd like to
share something with you though just
because it's a cool thing
I hope begging your pardon the
psychologists are interested now in
something called the default mode
Network and that refers to what your
nervous system does by default when it
goes back to its baseline state so our
attention is constantly drifting back
and forth between the external world and
our own internal worlds our own thoughts
the paper came out recently that was
exploring happy versus sad music and its
effect on the default mode Network and
these good scientists discovered that
happy music makes us focus on others and
the outside world more sad music turns
our attention inward and I presume that
this is true with movies that that happy
exciting things help us to folks focus
on the other whereas sad stories are
getting us to focus on ourselves that's
a this is the kind of work that's coming
out of out of brain science laboratories
that will inform storytellers in many
different domains in the future you're a
movie making
right right and I mean so I think for
for me
it's yeah it goes back in some way to
your very first question which is the
aim doesn't you know that's about
imitating people or here kind of
imitating these motor sensory
experiences of the physical world and I
think we don't always have to just aim
for that kind of fidelity to the
physical world instead we can think what
are the new types of experiences that
this medium can enable that we would not
have otherwise yes oh you could and so
the question about voice synthesis so I
was in the UK and I Greenwich at one
point and there were artists that
synthesized a voice that sounded like
Freddie Mercury from the band Queen and
things like not just try to fool people
but it was Freddie Mercury singing
linter Nationale he liked this grand
grand communist you know a good song or
ordering a pizza I think it's things
like they were totally banal and you
wouldn't expect hear from Freddie
Mercury yes so they were kind of
inverting your kind of your expectations
and so when I think about this question
about you know haptics and smell it's
more about what are the conventions that
will arise you know that is imagine a
movie like The Truman Show and you think
you're in a in this virtual theater in
this lush forest and this expansive
environment and then you reach out and
then you feel bars in front of you right
so that kind of like a counterpoint you
know that begins to exist at that point
or you have you know you're like
watching a film like Pan's Labyrinth at
one point in this I think it's a great
film and you have a laid out banquet
here and then you just smell this kind
of like sulfur smell that begins to
infiltrate despite the kind of lush food
that's laid out so again you have these
kind of counter points and like dropping
in and out and just at the right moment
so all of a sudden you feel something
that you don't expect to me that becomes
more interesting than only the kind of
fidelity the physical world it's all
these new possibilities for storytelling
you know you talked about the Turing
award at the beginning there's actually
something called the Loebner prize
whether they have a competition to see
if a machine can they have a machine I
think behind the stage behind a curtain
and have a person that try and the idea
is if your machine can fool the audience
into thinking it is the person you in
the Loebner prize and they do the reel
so on that note thank you very much for
exploring here
I think not Rita Rita Rita please go
back but you have to answer yes you
absolute as an old friend change and
then alum she gets to ask very quickly
understand the tenth gate user group
study that you performed what is the age
range right so think so it's so as a
series of studies so I mean it's I could
refer you to some papers for the
particular demographic breakdowns of
each one these are online studies and so
what we did is we built a computer
science learning game and so this is a
game in which in order to succeed you
have to write small programs to move a
character through a space and so
initially just arrows and you begin to
add conditionals and loops and so forth
and so in terms of metric we're looking
at things like how many times would the
person try how far did they get and so
forth then we also had validated
instruments so for their engagement you
know it's self-reported engagement with
the experience and so and that over 10k
was a series of cumulative experiences
so for example the very first one a kind
of simple shape versus a likeness avatar
you know so could be something like a
Nintendo me you know like these made to
look like you versus a very simple shape
and then comparing the kind of impacts
of each of yeah of each of these then
you have another one that might say
instant likeness like a photographic
likeness that's created instantly
compared to one in one of these kind of
shapes and so on and so each one is a
kind of incremental study that built on
the prior ones so you have to expand our
understanding there and one of the
things that we found actually worked the
best across the board regardless of
demographic groups was actually what we
call a successful likeness avatar so
this is the one when you're doing very
well within this experience then you see
something that looks like you and when
you're struggling somehow or not
performing as well as you could but
maybe you just pop up a dialog box or
you have just text or a kind of a simple
shape and that is basically reinforced
elf reinforcing that you see your
likeness when you're doing
well that we saw as one remedy against
and the stereotype threat across all the
demographic groups because instead what
you're doing then is reinforcing not
this the association of your likeness
but also your group with the kind of
positive performance and positive
engagement you know there but in terms
of the details of you because you know
it's maybe a batches of 500 you know 500
users I'm going to use those hybrid
users for each study then after for you
to the individual ones for a particular
breakdowns particular breakdowns there
but it gives you at least a sense of
what these experiments look like and
I'll in saying after the online
experiments we went into public schools
and so in that case it was high school
students actually work with high school
students for more in-depth qualitative
studies really of how they relate to
their avatar and how they respond when
they see their avatar standing in
between them and the computer science
learning subject matter terrific I think
the sort of the scientific basis behind
a picture of dorian gray right anyway
thank you very much
[Applause]